I was thinking maybe hamam is going to
be maybe second or third bro Daniel
first
um Jake second hello Robert third bro I
thought people with the animation video
no one's buying it no I'm fine no you
know emotional yeah I thought maybe
there might be some people there who are
emotional yeah no but people what wimp
what is little boy yeah he's a cow
exactly and nobody bought it you was
right at the bottom okay that's what you
deserved which is the hamam
do you want to speak with confidence
like these amazing personalities every
single one of these amazing speakers
have taken the same program with brother
Muhammad arshad Muhammad arshad has
helped develop all of us it's extremely
beneficial to do this course definitely
recommend this course
to access the free life-changing
training now
brothers and sisters and dear friends so
this is another reaction video to one
other part of the debate that happened
um today between uh brother Daniel Jake
um Robert and Rashid hamam yeah so we're
going to watch it inshallah and this is
the Crux of the matter when it comes to
the Trinity and why people in the
millions in the west have left
Christianity this is a practice and I
believe that's right Patrick's watching
this I think when he invites you uh to
the table of the Christian and the Jew
this should be the main fundamental
thing because this is what I agree this
is what people are lacking this is the
Crux of the matter so let's watch it
inshallah where Daniel here made a very
valid point distant Theology sunnis and
shias they all agree on the monotheism
God is one he is not like anything they
agree on the Quran yeah there can be
some theological differences and nuances
between different schools but there's
not the same kind of disparity or
variance between Christian sects and
this idea of the Trinity which frankly
no one can understand like what does it
mean to be three in one
my brother is mentioning divisions
between Catholics and Protestants if I
go back there are divisions among the
follower the Disciples of Muhammad the
sahaba themselves they killed each okay
he couldn't yeah so this is what Russian
hamam doesn't understand okay yes that's
why his arguments believe uh belong to
the hamam which is the toilet yeah no
I'll tell you why listen listen
Daniel said look he's talking about the
Trinity does not make sense okay that's
why they are afraid to even talk about
it you're right absolutely can you
imagine me absolutely at any course
avoiding talking about Allah and it's
wondrous it shows how insecure you are
now Daniel said something very
interesting yes you look at all the six
in Islamic there is certain things that
even coming when it comes to the
doctrine yeah yes Allah is one the
processor is the final messenger that's
right the Quran is
you're equating that with the sahaba
that for each other did they fought each
other until heed did they say no Allah
is three and one and they said no the
Allah is one only and Allah in one Allah
so they were taught maybe just to play
Devil's Advocate and I think he did kind
of mention this but he said it
incorrectly because he's he's a fool
actually I overestimated him I thought
somebody yeah absolutely because he was
saying there was a difference among the
scholars in early Islam he mentions it
somewhere whether or not the Quran is uh
created or Eternal actually it wasn't
about the eternality of the Quran or the
creative nature it was about whether
it's half and salt yes whether it's uh
whether it's letters and sounds uh
versus if it was created and yes the the
whole kidum of it was something which is
subsidiary issue but this is he
misrepresented the theological
discussion about going back to the point
if you look at the the major theological
discussions that happened in early Islam
they never concerned who was God
who the question is who is God exactly I
mean it's not even about what does God
do how does God do what he does how do
we describe God we're talking about the
wholeness of God and and Jake does a
very very good job and so does Daniel in
presenting this point but the fact is it
and he mentioned this Jake mentioned
this it took them to the fourth Century
to crystallize the co-equality and
cohortonality of the three persons of
the Trinity exactly and that if it was
self-evident why did it take that long
they couldn't respond and you could see
here rishita
when he when he was particularly
whatever his name is when he was asked
about that question yeah and he was
asked about that question he went
straight to the Muslims fighting in the
early days what's that got to do with
the Trinity here exactly why are you
running away this is cowardice you can
see the coward he is a coward yes he is
an absolute cow why don't you why don't
you face the main thing about your
religion one of the difference between
Islam Christianity is the Trinity one of
the biggest differences of course and
the moment is mentioned you run away and
you are right coward that means you know
deep down you can't defend your position
exactly well lie that that's what that
means it means deep down you can't
defend that position you are a coward
they're both cowards as soon as the
Trinity comes up which is the main
difference in fact that does have a
credible disproven implications that one
does have it if you disprove the
training you disprove of all of
Christianity exactly exactly that one
does have it and and yes exactly and
another point which we need to mention
as well is that you need to understand
the rhetoric that they're coming with
which I was I was shocked that how it
backfired on them because they were
coming with this whole restaurant of
Islam is violent inherently and we've
been hearing this for the past like I've
been Muslim for 10 years but before that
I think they've been talking about it as
well for the past 20 years their main
argument is what Islam is inherently
violent can you imagine that's the
strongest argument can you imagine bro
yeah now and that's the reason why he
keeps going to that that's why he went
to it yeah but you know what's very
profound actually people don't care
anymore that didn't work like he was
about he was about to even cry I saw one
moment it's like like you're gonna pray
like violin yeah it didn't work because
you look like like if we look at Aki
yeah what is the one of the main reasons
people are coming to Islam yes yeah the
fact that it is intolerant yes because
there's so much boundaries it has
boundaries people respect it even pet
Patrick yeah uh Patrick even admits
these there's certain things the point
is what your arguments are not working
anymore Islam being inherently violent
which is false but let's go with the
argument say how does that make Islam
false how does it that's the question
stand false so all these efforts you put
in the ex-muslims the Christians that
hate preachers the zionists all of them
together Islam is Islam is that for 10
years and imagine after that 10 years
imagine you're going to war and you're
going with one specific weapon and your
strongest argument your strongest
argument and guess what people are
coming to Islam for that reason and for
that bro you can't bro this is to me it
increases my faith in Islam because it's
like you were attacking Islam with this
one weapon now that weapon is a reason
why people come into Islam and to me to
see this guy crumble cry this happened I
just
so you can see the moment we speak and
the moment the brother spoke about and
Trinity yes they were terrified and what
would they keep going back to yeah Islam
is inherently yeah that is the only
thing they have yeah and it is not
working anymore
and let's look at the parts let's look
at the post it's right I look at the the
pole that yeah
exactly
I was thinking maybe hamam is going to
be maybe second or third bro Daniel
first
um Jake's second Robert third bro I for
people with the animation
bro no one's buying it no you know
emotional yeah I thought maybe there
might be some people there who are
emotional yeah no but people what wimp
what is
okay right at the bottom so what I'm
gonna say is I'm going to flush I'm
gonna flash this argument for Russian
I mean that's it and I believe Patrick
if you invite hijab the the focal point
of the discussion at hand should be
tawheed we are proud of our religion we
listen we don't sugarcoat we don't feel
the scriptures under the bus we don't
follow prophets under the bus to us it's
totally okay
the fact that we are like that this is
why people are flocking to Islam okay
and that's what we're going to say uh
from Muhammad Ali to Rashid hamam
inshallah uh